a couple people in the audience have
notified me about Marjorie Taylor green
2.0 okay this is a woman named Michelle
Fiore who is running for the
governorship of Nevada and quite frankly
um Marjorie Taylor green 2.0 seems like
a pretty good way to describe her
article in the Las Vegas Review Journal
embroiled in controversies Michelle
Fiore announces a run for governor Las
Vegas councilwoman Michelle Fiore said
Tuesday she will seek the Republican
nomination for governor casting herself
as a champion for conservative values
amid a Cascade of controversies that
figure to be election cycle targets
we're going to talk about those in a
moment but she is under FBI
investigation for campaign Finance
she's been accused of breaking uh a
fellow Council woman's finger in an
assault in City Hall
um and more so we're going to get to
that in a moment here is the Michelle
Fiore campaign ad it involves trucks it
involves guns and yes I think Marjorie
Taylor green 2.0 is a great nickname for
Michelle Fiore
I'm Michelle Fiore and I'm running for
governor
I spent my whole life fighting The
Establishment I was the first female
majority leader in Nevada assembly and
one of the first electeds to endorse
Donald J Trump and you better believe I
was attacked for it imagine as a badge
of honor bragging that you endorsed
Trump before most other people like as
if that's something good
[Applause]
magazine said that I was the lady Trump
and I don't care
we need Outsiders Fighters not the same
old boring moderate compromise blue
blazer politicians by the way if you're
only if you're only uh listening when
she said the same moderate politicians
she pushed over a TV that had an image
of Mitt Romney on it which which again
shows you the political alignment that's
happening within the Republican party
right now
[Music]
the Joe Biden Administration is coming
after me now understand that you know
she says ban vaccine mandates okay ban
critical race Theory by which I suppose
she means ban the teaching of critical
race theory meaning that the governor
decides what's taught in school rather
than teachers and Educators
um and then she says we're going to stop
voter fraud
um as governor of Nevada
you have no involvement in elections in
any state other than Nevada
and Nevada is not even one of the places
where it's been seriously now that it's
been serious anywhere but whether
they've really gone out of their way to
allege that voter fraud took place in
2020. there was a little bit of it but
really the states were Michigan uh
Pennsylvania Georgia Arizona so as
governor of Nevada what do you even have
to do with voter it's all crazy I'm
Michelle Fiore and I'm ready for the
fight
okay so she is in the middle of a number
of different uh problems the um in
December of 2014 it was reported that
the IRS filed dozens of tax liens
totaling a million dollars against her
and her home health care business
the liens against the businesses
involved unpaid employee payroll taxes
nice huh she said I am 100 in compliance
and blamed her ex-husband
uh she's dealt with the voiding of her
home health care license there's an FBI
investigation this is a very beleaguered
individual also in the days after the
storming of the U.S Capitol on January
6th she attended the Republican National
committee's winter meeting on Amelia
Island Florida where she said to the New
York Times I surely Embrace president
Trump so a number of different problems
and controversies for Michelle Fiore she
is a running for the governor of Nevada
and I think Marjorie she seems in some
ways even wackier than Marjorie Taylor
green
something about the video makes her seem
even more unhinged but maybe somebody
that we're going to get to know by the
way I also want to mention November 2nd
in Virginia there's a gubernatorial
election just because we're talking
about gubernatorial stuff if you live in
Virginia make sure you're voting on
November 2nd I plan to cover the results
of that race live I think it will be
interesting uh as Bill share told us
yesterday he said you know the results
of the gubernatorial race in Virginia
could impact Joe manchin's willingness
to do a or b when it comes to spending
infrastructure Etc so that'll be an
impactful and meaningful race in
Virginia November 2nd is the date is
that right I hope I'm yes November 2nd
so we're going to be streaming live the
results on that night